right Thompson espn.com ESPN the
magazine senior writer he's got a new
book the cost of these dreams sports
stories and other serious business
online and wherever books are sold if
you were gonna give a synopsis of this
book what would it be how would you
describe I would say the cost of these
dreams is about the greatest athletes in
the world and completely unknown people
all struggling with the same issues
about why do we do the things we do what
pushes us to try to be great and when
it's over what have we turned ourselves
into in exchange for it and I mean I
think like when you read them together I
had to do the book on tape and oh boy
there's nothing you talk about
confronting four days in a booth here in
your own voice yeah it was interesting
to me how they fit together as a book
and they speak to each other in a way
that I mean I'm not nearly smart enough
to have done that on purpose it just
sort of happened when you read them
together but you have Urban Meyer yeah
Pat Riley you have Tiger Woods you have
Michael Jordan just you know that's
where you start here and as McLovin said
you know the common denominator is
obviously successful but miserable you
know it's subtract I mean very much
trapped by the forces that the careers
are almost in some cases accidental
byproducts of them trying to manage
demons and forces especially Tiger and
Pat Riley and Urban Meyer and it's so
fascinating to me you know for a story
last year I spent a couple of days with
Dale Murphy you know the former baseball
player and I just had this moment I
realized he is the first 60-something
athlete I have ever met who's happy he's
in a great mood and he's happy and he's
like he's content with his choice he's
the anomaly though right he absolutely
is ain't none of these guys happy and
that is always fascinating to me about
you know you see these guys when it's
all over they have you know Michael
Jordan is very well aware of the fact
that Mike Jordan from Wilmington North
Carolina is dead and that Michael Jordan
killed him you know I mean they're vey
they're very aware of what
they've lost along the way okay how do
you get approval to go visit and be a
fly on the wall with Michael Jordan
watching basketball it's unbelievable I
asked and asked and asked and we was
very clear I read this New Yorker story
about Paul McCartney they said when I'm
64
it was about Paul McCartney turning 64
and I just was fascinated by the idea
that Michael Jordan was turning 50 which
you know my god what does that make me
and so I wanted to write a story about
him and Ageing and I sent the request in
and was basically I'm doing this with or
without him I mean if I if I have to
call every human being he's ever met
yeah that which is what the tiger story
ended up being yeah but because Tiger
didn't Tiger did not talk and I called
every human being he'd ever met do you
think he wishes that he talked just
soften that a little bit I mean I don't
yes I mean just if nothing else I got to
suck up real estate well they're all you
know control freaks but you know so
Jordan allows you to listen and we hung
out and watch basketball and watching
basketball with Michael Jordan is
unbelievably intense because you realize
he knows enough about the game and you
realized that he's scouting for games
he's never gonna play in like it's so
interesting to me he is so self-aware
that he constructed himself into someone
who was perfect at his job
and the problem is like all of those
carefully sharpened traits not only are
useless in his new life they're like
worse than useless because because
they're like the things that are
actively conspiring to keeping him from
hat from being able to enjoy having been
Michael Jordan and so Ike he knows it
that if he could put all of these he
sits there and plays that iPad game
bejeweled and it's like one of the best
people in the world at it and like
Michael Jordan I mean it's like some
it's like some great chef cooking in a
Waffle House it's just what like this is
what it's come to
do you know I mean he's playing Sudoku
he's like I beat you you know like it's
crazy but it but he's also watching
LeBron James yeah
and the competitor in him says you know
I'd force him left I'd make him shoot
that jumper if he goes right I can't
stop him so we like you can't turn that
off
no and it's it's interesting his playing
weight was 218 and so he when I saw him
he just gotten back from a vacation you
know eating and drinking and he gotten
up to like 250 something and so he came
back like all of us and hit the gym and
he said that when the pounds start
coming off and he gets to 240 in 235 and
to 32 and 29 he's like I start thinking
about can I get to 218 just in in his in
Jordan world 218 is the magic number
like if I can get to 218 maybe I could
play did he talk about the triangle
offense it was unbelievable like hey I
have this framed on the wall of my
office like we're sitting there and I
had a notebook and we're sweeping
watching basketball for hours and I'm
like I should have put that in the cost
of these dreams I should have just been
the cover is that because what I did is
I'm like can you explain the triangle to
me and he was just like give me that
notebook and he drew it and I'm sitting
there and he draws the basketball court
and the little axe he's like this is me
and then another X this is Scottie and
he's drawing lines and I'm just like you
know this is Michael Jordan is
explaining the triangle offense to me
and you know my face is melting off do
you know I mean I'm just like this like
there are a few moments where I'm just
like this is bananas like and Jordan let
you take the paper out I don't even
think he realized that he'd done it like
he just you know what I mean like he
just drew it and it was in my notebook
and when I started going through the
notebook later I was like oh my god but
like it was really interesting I mean we
spent I spent a lot of time around
around Jordan and yeah this sounds crazy
but like you would like him like he can
give it and take it yeah and like and
like you would like the guy but it took
him a while to become this well it
absolutely Tigers can't find that well
they older tiger it's what's really
interesting to me is that in some ways
Tiger was really let down by the people
around him who were packaging and
selling him because and you understand
why they did it when he started the best
and the most successfully marketed athil
the world is Michael Jordan and so
Tigers people following best practices
sold tiger exactly like Michael Jordan
yeah
but the real problem is is that Michael
is naturally an extreme extrovert and
Tiger is naturally an extreme introvert
and you know against that uptight thing
the mask eats the face I mean he in some
ways making him be someone in public
that he was spectacularly unsuited to be
was psychologically disastrous what if
Tiger said I'll give you two questions
right you can ask whatever you want and
I'll answer honestly what would be your
two questions for Tiger did you ever
like golf
and that's heavy and do you think he
likes going no I bet he likes golf now I
bet he I bet from 1997 to 2009 he did
not like golf and wondered why he played
and weight but he was so successful yeah
I mean I think golf he has him and he's
actually a genius I think and he is a
really incredible mind and I think
whatever if his dad would have
introduced him to gymnastics or if his
dad would have wanted him to be an opera
singer or if his dad would have wanted
him to be the world's greatest classical
guitar player I think he would have been
that I think that the pursuit of
greatness and of perfection was what he
liked I think now I wonder if he really
likes golf if it's this thing I would
ask him where he feels closest to his
father now would be my other question
those would be my two questions are
pretty but do you mean like you can't
him can you imagine if your
eleven-year-old boy whose parents are
getting divorced and are splitting up
and the happiest your family is is when
they're both watching you succeed at
golf and 12 to 18 goes really quickly
now you're in college you're the best
player in the world
now you're signing all of these deals
now you've won the Masters and you
haven't really had time to decide
whether you want your whole life to be
shaped by the unintentional whims of a
12 year old boy now imagine you're 30
and you have a wonderful life but none
of it is of your choosing but do you
think he's sabotage his life his career
I don't know and I thought about that I
mean I thought about that a lot
I don't I mean subconsciously possibly I
think that he certainly understood that
there was a difference between Eldrick
Tiger Woods and Tiger Woods and that one
was an avatar I imagine like lots of
famous people he came to hate the avatar
and also sort of liked it it's like the
Johnny Manziel thing he wanted to be
famous desperately and then when he got
it all he wanted was to give it back and
you can't you know the book is the cost
of these dreams and I can't emphasize it
enough just because Wright's not one of
the great sports writers he's one of the
great writers and and and that's what
hits you as soon as you start to read
this we're going down we're we're going
deep into the mind here you know I felt
like a canary I was going into the mind
and I was hoping I was gonna stay alive
no reading all of this you know it's
like a country road I don't know where
it's going you may not know where it's
going but you eventually get back home
well I like not knowing and I like not
having an idea when I go in to meet any
of these folks you know and you know who
did you feel sorry for that you actually
had a chance to talk to their empathetic
maybe yeah you know I felt it was
interesting because I felt sorry I felt
sorry for Michael Jordan and then I
talked to him several years later for
that Tiger piece and he seemed so much
happier then even a couple years but
getting married and having the baby yeah
and he just seemed really at ease and I
actually walked out of there and called
where my friends and I was just like man
I am so happy for Michael dude like he's
really happy yeah and he my god he
earned it which sounds strange though
you'd think it Mike's got everything
but you were there worried about him and
now honey I'm home Michael Jordan is
doing better yeah it's hilarious it's
like like I wouldn't want his fame
I would like his airplane I need an
airplane but like the you gotta sell a
lot of books yeah I mean do you know how
many like daddy needs a Gulfstream Urban
Meyer I I find him complicated I don't
know if he tries to be complicated I
just I don't know if he knows who he is
that's a very interesting question I
think one I think he's definitely
complicated I think one reason he's such
a good coach is that he it feels to me
like he is on a lifelong journey to
simplify because he's so complicated so
he the reason he gets people to believe
in things the reason that he as much as
anyone I've ever met wants to believe in
something he is a guy constantly
searching around for a belief system
that he can internalize and then pass on
to a group of 18 to 21 year old young
men I think that's why he's so good at
it does he believe what he's saying I
think that in the moment he says it he
believes every word he's saying I think
that the reasons he started coaching
were so personally important to him and
I imagine that you have to make so many
little and big compromises along the way
that he is still smart enough and
self-aware enough and sounds weird but
like at its core a really ethical person
and I think that the combination of
those things with all those compromises
probably makes them uncomfortable
sometimes to look in the mirror I mean
that's he didn't say that that's me
saying then but like you know what about
Pat Riley I love Pat Riley
I mean Pat Riley is probably he's of all
the people I've written about he's the
only one that I would keep in touch with
I got a email from him this morning
about the book I mean Pat is you know
when when my wife and I were trying to
have our daughter who's 15 months old
now Pat was unbelievably like you just
didn't get it you be in a doctor's
office and you look down and be
encouraging text Pat Reilly
and like you understood you understand
why he's so good at it like there's a
story I love about he was in the Bahamas
and Michael Jordan was in the bus I mean
I'm sorry I'm Magic Johnson was in the
Bahamas and Riley and it didn't use a
whistle he can whistle really loud like
just play I wish I could do them with
his fingers yeah I can't do them but
really loud and all of his players sort
of get the heebie-jeebies when they hear
it and so Riley and his wife Kris are on
a beach and she looks down she goes is
that Arvind and he's walking down the
beach and I was like oh my god it is so
he gets up and goes and hides behind a
sand dune and then just goes and lets it
out and said that magic was just like
then Riley stood up over the sand dune
and waved but like that's great
you know he's an interesting guy who you
know his father was a failed
professional athlete and he I don't
think could ever really be happy for Pat
success I mean like his I don't think
his dad saw him play a game in college
or the NBA and I think that you know the
night before that famous national
championship game against Texas Western
Riley was so stressed out that his feet
were breaking out and like almost like
open sores parents weren't at that game
his high school coach was in his hotel
room rubbing his feet so he could try to
sleep Riley's relationship with his high
school coach is I mean he isn't the guys
name was Walt prison below and Riley
loved him and in some ways Riley's
always trying to be for people what Walt
was for him I mean it's interesting
because I mean he adores his high school
coach you know that scene in Hoosiers
where Dennis Hopper runs out drunk that
actually happened to Pat Riley in a high
school basketball game he's running back
down the court to get back on defense
and here's murmuring and he turns around
and his father who was underneath the
bleachers watching Riley didn't even
know he was at the game staggers out
onto the court drunk and they have to
stop the game and Riley's coach all I
can think about is just poor Pat and so
Riley goes and gets Pat's dad and gets
him on the bench and sort of you know
and like Ryan
he adored while prison below and still
does I mean I think one of Walt's sons
was a scout for a long time for the heat
I mean you know Riley's one of those
guys when his college roommate at
Kentucky died the family walked into the
church the morning of the funeral I
think was probably during an NBA season
and the only two people in the church
are the priest and Pat Riley who's flown
in who's sitting in there waiting and
like he sees ones guys who shows up do
you think you're gonna do one of these
deep dives on the bran yes I hope so
but are you interested or is there
somebody else if I said you can do one
of your patented deep dives
you can pick anybody that's a really
interesting question you know I would
really like to do I mean LeBron I would
really like to do I mean Christiano
Ronaldo I'm just completely fascinated
by because there seems like there's no
there there which means there has to be
like a really complicated I mean no one
is that vapid like join me like that
can't be it like it can't just be like
oh no he really is a [ __ ] like it can't
be like sometimes I wonder like do you
think he can say like seven words like
ball you know like so but you're more
interested in Ronaldo than Messi I am
more interested when I've written about
Messi and I feel like Messi Messi is
another one of those people who the
decisions he made as a thirteen-year-old
boy he now is do you think he's trapped
like Tiger I don't think he's a smartest
Tiger so I don't think he probably feels
his trapped let me I think Tiger is
legitimately like off-the-charts
brilliant like you know in a way that
say Jack Nicklaus isn't okay you know I
mean like you know you know their Tiger
is a fascinating guy I mean I'd love to
go back to Tiger I think he would let
you back after what your own but it's
interesting I mean like I'm that's a
really interesting question I mean I
have a couple of things going I'm
interested in
both Swinney really what about Steven
I'm very interested in saving because it
seems to me to be such a lesson of if
you just do little things over and over
and over it turns into a big thing but
is that Belichick in that yes I I wonder
about that like I wonder if if you could
flip them I wonder if there's something
about Nick that allows him to do this
with people of that age and I wonder if
Belichick has that advice of are so like
I wonder if if they switched offices and
everything else about those teams stayed
the same if either of them would succeed
like I and I don't know the answer to
that so you think Nick is better at the
18 to 21 year old whereas Belichick
needs you to be a little bit more mature
than that I think there's a very
interesting case to be made that that's
true the book as you can tell the great
stories there and it's called the cost
of these dreams sports stories and other
serious business online wherever books
are sold and stamp of approval on my end
one of the great writers in America
write Thompson great to see you bud of
course and Congrats with the baby thank
you so much he's really fun yeah and
good luck on your Gulfstream I'm working
on that I'm gonna paint a picture of my
son you're gonna be working on the
Gulfstream I have lo got a guy - gotta
go I'm gonna walk around
Oh mr. Patrick can I make you a martini
that's great
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]